mortgage costs they're going up but just
how much well the bank of England has
done some work on this it's quite
interesting it's showing you it's kind
of breaking down over the course of the
coming months how many households so the
bars are showing numbers of households
are facing relatively small increases
pretty big increases and very big
increases in their monthly mortgage
payments that's going through is the end
of 2023. just look at what happens
afterwards so going through to 2026 if
you add all of that up that is nearly 1
million households facing an increase of
more than 500 pounds or 500 or more a
month so six thousand pounds or more a
year it just gives you a sense of the
scale of what's being faced some people
are facing even bigger increases than
that raising a question what does this
mean for the overall Financial system
well have a look at this this is showing
you the percentage of households so the
higher that is the bigger the proportion
of households who face really high debts
at the moment basically debts that are
worth about 70 of your income those were
really high at the times of financial
crisis the interesting thing and quite
striking here given how high interest
rates are is this line is still quite
low and even if interest rates go up a
fair bit in the next few months the bank
of England thinks it's still a long way
shy of where it was back at the
financial crisis so a little bit of good
news there although it all of course
depends on what happens to interest
rates if they go up a lot then that
could well change and that depends on
this other line it depends on inflation
so much comes back to this this actually
is U.S inflation again the higher the
line is the faster the rate of prices
going up and look laser space has just
come in it's actually showed that's
coming down it's close to normal levels
about three percent in the US look at
the Eurozone that's also coming down but
here's the odd one out look the UK
unfortunately still very high inflation
kind of went along up with everyone else
and stubbornly high at 8.7 percent and
now everything ultimately depends on
what happens to that red line does it
come down in the future that'll have a
big bearing on interest rates and pretty
much everything